hello everyone and welcome to another
YouTube hangout super excited to be here
with my special guest and friend Peter
sage peter is what isn't Peter Peter is
an entrepreneur a speaker and author a
mentor a philosopher a youtuber and he
shared the stage with Richard Branson
and Bill Clinton and he's here today to
talk to us about how you can reinvent
yourself Peter welcome aboard Ivan what
a pleasure to be here and I'm fabulous
in today's technology we can we can
stream this out alive what a great
opportunity I love it and and peter has
a great youtube channel as well that I
encourage you guys to check out I've
included in the description below if
you're an entrepreneur this is an insane
value there on how to build a business
and if you're not an entrepreneur is
still a lot of value there about
personal growth and development and how
to become a better human being with a
lot more impact so if you're fan of my
channel you'll be a fan of Peters and
highly encourage that you check that out
today we're talking about how to
reinvent yourself and so Peter you've
got me curious how do I know how does
someone know if they need to reinvent
themselves how does that start what does
the process look like well a great
question I think that the foundation of
that is are you in a process right now
of looking to change what it is that
you're doing are you satiated or is
everything happy do you have the the
magic sweet spot of life where
everything is happening which usually
isn't the case or are you struggling to
you know get out of repeating a lot of
the same patterns that many of us do
throughout our lives albeit with
different stories attached to more
different circumstances of different
players in the game and so if you've got
that level of sort of frustration where
you think you know something I know
there's more to life than this I know
there's a better way than this and it's
just not quite working for me maybe it's
no longer time to try to change your
circumstances which is what many people
focus on maybe it's time to reinvent who
you are because everything starts there
so I know you've got a book coming up
next year talking about this and you
have a three day program where you
really immerse yourself in helping
people change their lives
obviously the limited time that we have
what are some of the steps that you
guide people through of how they can
reinvent
themselves well again everybody wants to
sort of quick magic pill and I think in
the time that we've got available here
what I really want to do is guide people
into some areas of focus that can really
add some value and the first one that I
always pick is about asking better
questions questions direct our focus and
if you're not directing your own focus
I've got news for you there's a lot of
people that pay a lot of good money to
Madison Avenue to figure out how to do
it for you and yeah and that's yeah and
that's not the life you want to live
being programmed by other people's
agendas and you know I liken the mind to
a compass needle yeah it can only point
in one direction at a time and the
challenge is just like if we take a
needle of magnetize Italy back in high
school yeah you take a magnet a power
source and you align it and keep
stroking that needle in one continuous
direction so that needle aligns to the
magnetic field and becomes coherent
pointed at all of the ions point in one
direction it becomes magnetized now our
mind is very similar if we are open to
unconsciously being programmed which
unfortunately as human beings we are you
know we wear a 24/7 constant adaptation
machine now our mind and our body now we
understand the body part that's easy now
the physical side of life everybody gets
because they have experiential evidence
of now your body will adapt if you put
it in McDonald's or if you put it in the
gym it doesn't mind it will adapt
accordingly
yeah that's its job but our mind is far
more programmable far quicker than our
body and if the magnet that the strong
force is constantly magnetizing us is
usually the media and our peer group and
if those two aren't optimal then you
know we're going to be sucked along for
the ride and don't really magnetize our
true north for ourselves so by asking
better questions well it does it shift
the direction of that needle now the
challenge is you can only do that for
ten percent of the time that you're
conscious or sleeping away because how
most people are 90 percent of the time
that's why when we're driving to work we
can't remember
two kilometers on the freeway that what
happened but now if if we focus on being
able to magnetize or take charge of
which direction a compass needle is
pointing we have a chance to start
reinventing ourselves because otherwise
yeah again you're going to be drifting
especially in that 90 percent at the
time when we do things out of habits
unconsciously that compass needle drifts
back to its precondition magnetic north
and most of time that doesn't serve us
whether its media condition peer group
condition and gear Society condition so
now look out of your window there's not
many examples who we really want to
emulate and become the surround us on a
day to day basis so you know the first
question is yeah or the first step is
ask better questions yeah and yet what
what ignites you you know what what
causes you to come from a place of
wanting to really give your gift not
survive in today's world because you've
got a mortgage to make not take the path
of certainty which if for entrepreneurs
if they haven't figured it out yet as
I'm sure you let them know as well yet
there is no certainty in life now so the
ability to handle uncertainty is one of
the core characteristics of an
entrepreneur and so to be able to do
that ask yourself bad questions now what
what resources do I have that I'm not
using yet
great question other because it'll start
you looking in different areas now this
is one of the best things about the
human brain is if you ask the question
it'll give you the answer the challenge
is most of us ask lousy questions now
why is this always happen to me
and it'll give you an answer it's
program cheating right here's your
worthless because you deserve it because
you're not smart enough at all so by
asking better questions we can search
for better answers that's really the
first place to start I love it is there
a series of questions that you recommend
everybody ask themselves we're in kind
of regardless of the situation so the
you know what ignites me what what gives
me passion what resources do I have that
I'm not currently using or some that you
mentioned other others that you
recommend people kind of get into the
habit of asking themselves yes and it
really ties into what I'm call really
that the next part of getting into
reinventing who you are and that is to
check your why you know we're driven by
reasons as human beings yeah everyone
those things for reasons now that may
not be your reasons may not be my roots
but we do things for reasons most of the
time unfortunately we do very little out
of logical reasons now we do a fair
amount other passion but most of what we
do we do out of habits and those habits
are formed based upon the repetitive
questions we tend to ask ourself which
usually is suboptimal and so if you were
to ask questions that elicited your
reason why and here's what I found in
the three decades of being an
entrepreneur now that is almost
universal consistent if your Y is
focused on you or not powerful you're
not present you don't have the ability
to dig deeper than you could unless it
was rather than if your Y is focused on
something greater than you and yet we
can see this in evidence everywhere I
give a classic example you take the New
York or the Boston Marathon boss thinks
it's more probit so the New York
Marathon is a goal for a lot of people
in their fitness sort of the resolutions
and for those that haven't ren american
before it's a good goal takes a lot of
training you know I've run crazy stuff
before and it's not easy if you're not a
professional athlete so if you take New
York you know 35,000 people lining the
streets cheering you on the amount of
people that run the New York Marathon
for the first time not the people that
do it for finalizer as an athlete on a
regular basis but for the first time
there is way your percentage of those
people that complete the marathon that
are running for something else not
themselves not their ego not the medal
not significance not the bragging rights
to support somebody they love in memory
of somebody they cared about to raise
money for a cause they believe in
something beyond themselves and that's
because those that are running for
themselves most of those quit before the
day of the marathon it's a lot to dig
deep when you're just looking at going
out of ego so question is that ask you
yet to reevaluate your why and most
people's why by default is grounded in a
area that really is fear driven what if
I fail
therefore my why for doing this is
because I think it's going to give me
the best chance of success not because
I'm passionate about it not because it's
giving my gift to the world not because
it's something I've always wanted to do
so asking questions like you know if I
knew it was impossible to fail what
would I do then it removed the fear of
failure away and open up possibility
thinking and what it'll do it'll start
getting you in touch with what inspires
you what lights you up what gives you
that that lift not the motivational
factor which is usually avoiding pain
and needs a willpower to get you through
getting up at 5:00 a.m. when it's cold
inspiration you don't need that
motivation motivation is a fuel tank in
a quiet rooms out it needs topping up
inspirations a deeper wellspring you
know asking questions like if I could
only spend my life doing one thing what
would it be and and start tuning
yourself into that that passion center
that a lot of the time we build bars
around you know to to imprison it
through not having to face the
possibility of failure and therefore
admit to ourselves we're not enough
which is usually what I see with so many
entrepreneurs that are burning
themselves out there running patterns of
chasing things that they think will give
them the success that will validate them
in the eyes of others whether it's their
parents their business studies teacher
their elder brother who they perceive
that always trying to be in the shadow
of it doesn't matter we've all got our
reasons whereas if you're independent of
what I call swimming in goop geoo P the
good opinion of other people musculars
and their life swimming in goop it's a
sticky nasty smelly mess that will lead
you to a fast track to mediocrity and
nowhere and so if you can escape the the
good opinion of other people and stand
proud in your truth that win lose or
draw I'm not taking it with me now the
only people that tried that with the
Egyptians and what happened 3,000 years
later we dug it up installer you know
I'm here to make the time I've got count
I'm here to make a difference I'm here
to give my gift and now you can only do
that with the freedom of being
independent of the fear of not being
enough or the fear of having to adapt
myself consistently like a chameleon to
fit the pictures of what I think other P
should see me as rather than say listen
yeah I respect the way in your attic
we're always going to see things
differently because that's who we are as
human beings that celebrating my truth
and I'm walking this way no one's
talking me out of it and providing that
nobody's less than because you craft
their path you know there's a moral
basis to that then yeah so in the back
with a smile and strike out a hit a home
run bus from the back I love it I love
it Peter goes I'm a Raines
I love it you can move on to the rain so
we're getting a lot of people watching
live and the chats kind of blowing up
and I thought we'd hit up some of the
questions here to give some love to the
audience in the first one kind of
related to what you're seeing about goop
uh missus Bugs Bunny 82 is ready to ask
how can I say no to others great
question and if you want to see an area
where people destroy themselves it's
around yeah their fear of rejection yeah
and so let me give you a metaphor for
this that I think may help we all starve
in a very specific movie yeah movie
called our life and as the star of that
movie yeah we have various different
people that are cast into that movie now
if we're lucky we'll have some
supporting cast you know a spouse yeah a
close friend or one habit but 99% of the
people that star or come into the movie
that use starring call to your life are
going to be film extras now if we in the
course of going through our movie when
we make a fundamental error because we
experience was the star we fundamentally
believe that everybody else sees us as
the star in our movie but they're gone
you see what happens is everybody else
is starring in a movie called their life
which by definition means that at best
we will only ever be a supporting cast
for a few of them and for most 99% of
people we will be nothing more than a
film extra in their movie now when you
come to say no it's the fear
of rejection is usually what's driving
that the avoidance of the fear of
rejection is usually what's driving that
and so if you start to understand that
we're all running around in this bubble
called a star of our movie thinking oh
my god everybody's looking at me as the
star of my movie forgetting that most
people don't care enough about you to
bother to give an opinion of who you are
in your movie because they're too busy
being worried about what they think
you're thinking of them as the star in
their movie everybody's got this bubble
factor going on it's a big illusion
where we're also kind of craving
approval of validation yeah a good
opinion and all of that and it's a ghost
it doesn't actually exist now so if you
start to understand that if I'm going to
say no to somebody and it's my truth
there's a couple of different ways you
can do that yet you can yeah say it
because you disagree and you think
they're wrong well I'm sorry that's yeah
that's going to offend somebody because
then they're going to be shot down as
the star in a movie thinking being
worried about what you think of them and
now going into a reactive pattern or you
can order your own truth independent of
somebody else while making sure that
they feel okay about this so if somebody
asks me to do something if I'm not
willing to say oh right now I'm afraid I
don't have the ability to do that you
know maybe I can connect you with some
resources that can but for me right now
that's not a - that's not much of to do
then you have to start understanding
this your role is to walk your path not
pander to everybody else's movie you're
starring in your own movie and second
you compromise that the second you give
away your truth the second you're
essentially giving up the role of the
star of your movie and in saying hey who
whose movie can I be a filmmaker in
that's not where you were born yeah
because the alternative is to be a
martyr now I don't want to say load of
something in case I have fed them maybe
that's the lesson that they need to stop
taking advantage of everybody who's
scared to say no and that's a gift that
you can give them now but you don't
focus on that because you're focused on
offending people and how they think
you'll essentially be rejected so you
know there's elegant ways of doing it
say you don't have to be an idiot about
it if you say it with loving firmness
because you're more committed to serve
by being Ewing your truth rather oh yeah
of course I'll do that oh no let me take
that on which is really this um this
chameleon of supplication denying your
own power you can give so much more to
somebody standing in your truth right
and we admire people like that do we not
know we would rather do business with
something where we see wow I really
respect that person because they they
appreciate their own boundaries doesn't
mean say you've got a bar of somebody
off up with a shoulder with your
boundaries yeah I love them through it
would be the example of how somebody can
step up and own themselves at that level
and you'll find that what you thought
would happen which you'll be judged
you'll be unfriended you'll be
criticized 99% the time doesn't happen
and if it does is there research that
they're projecting not the fact that
there's anything wrong with you
declaring your truth but the helps I
love it I love the analogy to of living
your own movie I think it's easy to get
caught up in somebody else's movie
instead of live in your own
next up the Lord Ivan Seto I often get
motivated uh for a while but I what can
I do to consistently stay motivated
every day and maybe that hasn't here why
exercise from before but how do you say
motivated consistently every day again
staying motivated is tough because
motivation is not on call it's like a
sport button in a car you press it when
you need to overtake somebody when you
need some extra power but if you run the
engine constantly on sport mode you've
never wear it out before its time and so
motivation is great but there are times
we all know we just ain't motivated and
no matter how what the heads are and
it's those times we can't afford to rely
on motivation and that's like if you're
trying to get motivated to stay
motivated right now it's never going to
happen
for start don't beat yourself up about
it it doesn't mean to say that you're
not good enough that there's something
wrong with you that you need to work
harder that you need to build your
motivation muscle yeah we're just not
wired for that level of constant
progress you know I can have all all the
motivation to hang on to a branch of a
tree over a cliff but if you come back
in three days I'm not there you know
it's it's not going to happen so
understanding the difference between
your being inspired yet which isn't like
this crazy
elevation let's go get em cowboy kind of
deal now you look at something like
Mahatma Gandhi one of the greatest
inspirational figures in modern history
he didn't have all of this pent-up
energy kind of you know rah rah I'm
going to get up at 5:00 it no there was
a calm surrender to a mission that was
bigger than him and if we just look at
that word for example surrender most
people that are motivated thinks
surrender means to give in to give up to
capitulate sit acquiesce to be left
stands if they're sellout whereas the
more enlightened the more your the
higher the level of consciousness the
more the emotional maturity that one
progresses to you by getting out of our
own egos and significance needs and
start focusing on what we can contribute
to life rather than take from it it
starts a here to surrender from a
different point oh I've got to get up at
5:00 a.m. for the next three weeks to
get this project done I'll simply
surrender to that because the project
yet means more to me from an
inspirational perspective because I'm
giving my gift then it does yeah needing
to stay motivated so I can be good
enough by getting a tip box on the
project so again check your Y if you
need to motivate yourself you're wise
not big enough or it's as big as you can
make it about you and that'll never be
big enough good I like it cool next up
so what what should one do when it's
difficult to choose the area of interest
for ourselves simple yeah when you come
to a fork in the road what do you do you
take it yeah the the challenges that our
left brain is designed to do one thing
and it does it so impeccably that we
tend to miss the point as to why it does
it and our left brain is designed to
balance the equation of being right now
it'll justify it'll self analyze it'll
come up with all sorts of associate
reasons to say you know why it should or
shouldn't we should I shouldn't do
things but its job is to make you right
the way that you emotionally feel yeah
and its it's a muscle that's over
developed through 20th and 21st century
educational systems we've
focus on left brain activity because
that can be measured or the objectivity
can be measured subjectivity can't so
you know we study math so we study
science and we take tests and then we
score 75% and we can be measured how do
you take a test for creativity
imagination how much you love somebody
yeah emotional expression yeah they're
just not encouraged so the left side of
the brain gets built like walking into
the gym with huge biceps and skinny legs
you know that the right side of the
brain doesn't get much traction so we
tend to default to the left side of the
brain and in a situation where I say how
do I choose between the two what's
really going on most of the time and if
this isn't true for you yeah then that's
okay but what in my observation what's
going on is how do I procrastinate so
that I don't have to face the fear of
actually doing something and committing
to it because my history around that
isn't inspiring enough to validate the
fact that I'm not going to fail so oh do
I do left or do I do right well they're
both good on the left side of the brain
at that point jumps in as a complete
college job to start evaluating and SWOT
analysis and processes and minuses and
go ask my friends and do all this know
you will get the feedback you need by
walking one of the paths yeah no need to
have stress no need to yeah Tricia said
ask yourself the qualifying question if
I could only do one or the other for the
rest of my life which would it be
and you'll tend to find that one has its
basis in certainty oh well I think I
should do this business because I think
I've got a better chance of getting into
the market quicker but it totally
doesn't turn me on in terms of what I'm
doing or you know oh well yeah this
particular business there's less chance
of success but boy you know I really
don't really feel something for it so
again the left side of the brain will
balance your ability to avoid fear and
go with certainty
whereas yeah what really should be going
on is saying you know pick one and then
work off the feedback as to what comes
that way you know if you've stuck in the
road and there's a fork and you you sit
there for two hours debating which way
they go on the map whereas if you'd have
taken one and it turned out to be a
dead-end you'd have already come back
and trip to the other one yeah nothing
in this life is undo
now when it comes to making decisions a
new future is always available so you
know don't think it's finite or life and
death pick one and go forward and if
yeah after three weeks it seems like
it's the wrong decision yeah
pick something yeah it's okay yeah learn
and see what the difference was for next
time I love it I love all the analogies
you use - it's really good it's easy to
follow along and people are freaking out
in the Chad this is powerful stuff great
subject they love you so so it's good
next up Amy is asking about reinventing
yourself how do you know that you're in
the right direction of reinventing
yourself easy you don't again remember
we talked about in terms of the ability
to handle uncertainty however there are
points is that I can give and that is to
understand as we just touched on briefly
the difference between what I call the
thinking center and yet the feeling
center yeah the thinking center yeah
will essentially talk you in and out of
everything that is des design to avoid
the emotions that you feel unconsciously
are uncomfortable now
I'll say that again this critical point
your thinking center is predominantly
designed to justify courses of action
that will lead you to avoid emotions
that you voted on as being uncomfortable
such as rationalizing why you should say
yes to somebody instead of no because
that we know they're really nice I'll do
it this once and case in point so the
thinking of center will always sell you
were dummy now it'll be wrapped up in
amazing wrapping paper
it'll be shiny it'll look like it's you
know the right choice yeah trust me and
you've heard everyone really has
examples of this that I don't have to
yeah point but the feeling sense is
different to your heart listening to
your heart it's a different language the
heart only knows two things and it's a
binary response with the body fear or
love that's it now you can rephrase it
any way you want positive negative feels
good feels bad move towards move away it
doesn't matter the same thing that's
going on every cell
your body has two states growth and
protection fear and love now at a
biological level a lot of different
things go on yeah if you come from
justifying it but there's that little
niggling thing because you can't lie
over the top of unresolved self feelings
from the heart the heart knows truth
your truth yeah this is always
subjective it is your truth so your
cells will go into a protection
mechanism to a point where they will
squeeze the blood out of them through
the viscera out of the organs into the
muscles because you're in protection
mode now you don't go hit somebody with
your spleen you hit them with you you
know your fists so you know if you're
fearful or something's not right you'll
have a physiological response to that
it'll even squeeze blood out of the
frontal lobe into the rear brain so you
can act off reflex which is more
protective I'm trying to figure out
which strategy to you know duck or hit
with and then ya end up getting
sucker-punched so you become less
intelligent and you become more stressed
when you operate from fear instead of
love now here's the problem if you put
them the mind and the heart on opposite
sides of the debate table which is kind
of what we're being asked here in the
question who wins well it's usually the
mind why because it's right and it knows
truth no because it has access to more
tools logic reasoning language deduction
metaphor yeah labels yet all of that
stuff is the job of the mind but the
heart doesn't care what the mind
rationalizes Harlow's truth your truth
which may be different to somebody else
is treating of it they're the only truth
with a capital T is the fact that we
don't know the damn truth that's that's
the only true that you can really take
to the bank
that's so you know what your truth is
which I believe is the reason we're here
is to be authentic not to be happy not
to be rich yeah but to be authentic and
in the process of being authentic in
business we tend to get happy and rich
now as a by-product or a consequence not
as a as a destination as a journey so
you know how do you know yeah which path
to take you already know which path to
take
there's people listening to and watching
us right now ever than the
walk down the aisle with somebody that
they knew yeah that sounded good on
paper but ticked every single box but
they felt something different from the
heart and within two three four five
years yeah that truth became more
self-evident now it's you know so the
feeling sensor is what you want to trust
not emotions that's different yeah
feeling sense should be like gut feel
yeah it's that intuition that inner
feeling emotions are just the after
products of thoughts that's all so don't
get caught up in your emotions where we
also make decisions from now has have
still a logical basis you don't want to
yeah something starter yeah business
selling how sprigs in the Arctic has
have some similar that's where the mind
is useful to come and validated here
they're the actual decision but lead
with the heart and and let the mind
serve that was at all about I love it I
have a feeling people are going to want
to re-watch this a couple times so
everything's sink in to fully digest
what you're saying it's great maybe time
for one last question
Vijay's writing in and this is kind of
on topic how do I get out of my comfort
zone
well probably we watch this and take
some notes and yeah I say that somewhat
facetiously but we've been covering a
lot of that it's about getting a why
that that's bigger if you're in your
comfort zone see the comfort zone acts
almost like the rumble strip on the
freeway yeah and there's many rumble
strips in other words you're going down
and what happens you start to drift to
the side because you're not paying
attention and the next minute is to
describe the work you up now we have
many different forms the rumble strip of
life can present itself one of them is
procrastination being bored sitting in
our comfort zone life is saying hey dude
alright this isn't where you're going go
get up you know and go go find something
that inspires you that motivates you get
out of your own way start getting out
and swinging the bat you know or stop
being shy
that's another excuse that's a racket
that most people yea sometimes hide
behind if you already dissolve shy I can
do it in one sentence yeah shiz please
don't let you discover me because I'm
afraid of what you may judge me for yeah
it's a racket go back to the movie store
metaphor doesn't exist now get in the
game and swing the bat the other rumble
strip could show up as an illness
now as a you've been driving down the
freeway of you
our eating healthy and then you start
drifting off to the side towards some
fast food or some unhealthy habits and
boom guess what shows up are your stage
two announcer you've got diabetes you've
got one have you
it's a rumble strip yeah no problem it's
okay thank the rumble strip for being
there don't resist it what most people
do is they all this rumble strip is
interfering with the music that's in my
car I'll just turn the music up louder
and carry on what I was doing now you
pay attention its feedback people come
to me with an illness and I said when
was the last time you made that illness
your friend instead of your enemy thank
it for the job that it's doing and it
tends to go a lot away a lot quicker but
that's a mind shift that's very yeah in
loggerheads with many different forms of
traditional medical views because they
don't understand the metaphysical side
they just ignore it and when the placebo
effect shows up they call it an anomaly
and a week that's a whole other
conversation but yeah so yeah motivate
yourself by stop trying to be motivated
and recognize that that's a rumble strip
yeah and in procrastination get inspired
go help somebody else though dead ik 8
yourself to a cause that puts the smile
on somebody else's face because that's
when we feel most alive and that's when
we're really being who we shouldn't be
at that core and giving a gift I love it
Peter feel like we could we could talk
for hours and hours people would still
be lining up with their questions people
are freaking out in the chat while
next-level stuff this is awesome that
was good this is crazy good today people
are going crazy I know we're a time for
people who want to follow up they just
discovered you they want to learn more
about what you're doing your book your
website YouTube channel what's the best
place to reach out to you what's the
thing that you're you're focusing on
right now that people can find you out
great what we do obviously there's a lot
of stuff on my youtube channel which
you're easy to find them and thanks for
in the linking my website peter sage
calm nice and simple if you want to come
and play with me at some of the events
that we do we're yeah we get to spend a
few days together and really go deep on
some of the aspects of reinvention then
reinvent yourself iö is a place you can
go and learn more about that and yeah
it'd be an absolute pleasure and a
privilege to for anyone wants to come
and play a participate or for those that
are starting their business or really
looking for some stuff I put as much as
content as I can on my youtube channel
just to help as many people as I can so
yourself always inspire me as well love
it well guys thank you so much for
watching really appreciate all the
questions that we also couldn't get to
Peter I just super appreciate the time
today and in your awesome YouTube
channel I learn a lot from it as well
thank you guys so much continue to
believe and we'll see you soon really